[موسيقى]
انا اشتغل في بورصه الكويت وطلب الدراما
الخليجيه طوال اللقبه ان تقوم بتغيير
موضوعاتها وان تصبح هناك موضوعات جديده
بعيده عن الطلاق والميراث وغيره حتى جاء
مسلسل الصفقه مسلسل مختلف يطرح قضيه جديده
من نوعها المراه الكويتيه عندما ضربته
لاول مره في البورصه هذه هي قضيه المسلسل
الذي تعتمد على نفسك السعاده مكان وزمان
مكان هذا العمل جميل كذلك زمن هذا العمل
اجمل بالثمانينات فلذلك انا كنت سعيد انه
امثل هذه الحقبه لان انا عاصرتها وشفتها
بالثبان الناس لما كان البورصه كانت
موجوده
والاسهم مستندات والشركات هي
من الاساس فتره الثمانينات غنيه وبالتحديد
بالكويت بالخليج والتحديد بالكويت غنيه
على مستوى الثقافه والرياضه والفن
والسياسه وكل الاحداث
وبالدرجه الاولى هي فترتنا انا ربيت فتره
الثمانينات وكل ذكرياتي الجميله كانت فتره
الثمانينات من الفترات اللي اعشقها واحبها
وما ترددت ابدا لما لما جاني الاتصال من
نتفليكس لانتاج هذا العمل الناس نفسه يعني
يتكلم عن كيف ان المراه دخلت سوق الاسهم
ونافسه الرجال
عرفتي ونجحت فاحنا انت ما تركز على مسلسل
مسلسل انت تركز على ابطال لهم شرف
الاسبقيه في ان الناس الاخرين تبعوهم في
شيء كان شبه مستحيل البنت كانت دائما تدور
ولا الفرصه وانت تشتغل في مكان يناسبها
ويناسب عائلتها وتحس بحريتها الملتزمه
الحلوه النظيفه يعني كوزين انا عايشه
بعالمين منفصلين عالم يخصني وعالم يخص
في المسلسل مختلفه لانها تقدم المراه
القويه في الثمانينات واللي تصنف انها
المرحله الاغنى بالنسبه للمراه الكويتيه
والتحضير لهذه الشخصيه مسؤوليه كبيره
ولذلك توقفنا مع روان ومنى لنعرف كيف
حضروا للشخصيات اللي قدموها للنساء
حقيقيات من الثمانينات
شخصيا كنت وايد ابحث عن فيديوهات شفت وايد
لقاءات لان هذا اللي قدرت اشوفه في هذه
الحقبه لقاءات فنانات ولقاءات ناس مهمه
فخذيت منهم طريقه الكلام
الرزانه القعده لهم طريقه مختلفه يعني
تحسين انه انه يمكن بالنسبه لنا قديمه لا
هي مو قديمه هم كانوا حريم اول او حريم
الثمانينات بالذات كانوا قويين وراكدين
عرفتي طبعا كان كان هو البروسيس البحث في
دراسه طويل جدا خصوصا ان الثمانينات
والبورصه لازم ادرس عن البورصه ندرس عن
الاشياء شويه اللهجه طبعا في نساء معينات
من الفتره هذه كنت اطالعهم في يوتيوب
والحاله الداخليه اوريدي يعني ثريه من
النص ملهمه فجاء طبيعي مع الطاقه
المخرجين والانتاج البيرفكت معاك يعني في
كل تفصيله
صوره التنميه والتقدم
[موسيقى]